[Musique]
ce paquet vient d'arriver
faites venir tout le monde ici
jouez-moi
[Musique]
bonjour les banques détectives
savez-vous où sont vos officiers
jigsaw
eh bien je pensais que le tueur au puzzle était
mort il est
[Musique]
trouvez-le près des heures pas des jours  comment puis-je
attraper ce gars s'il n'y a personne dans la
force je peux m'occuper
tu ne peux pas faire ça seul
celui qui a fait ça a un autre motif
quelque chose de personnel
était la dernière fois que tu as vu ton père
[Musique]
tous les officiers des unités disponibles
c'était juste un  diversion pour nous faire sortir
de l'enceinte
j'ai besoin de tout le monde sur ce gâteau
pourrait être n'importe où
il pourrait être n'importe qui
nous allons déchirer cette ville